tu es chiant essayer de changer ton
image on va faire une interview
changement d'image
est-ce que pour changer votre image vous
pourriez ne pas sourire tout le temps
je serai tout le temps que le cheval
est-ce que pour changer votre image vous
pourriez arrêter de tutoyer tout le
monde
mais je vais y arriver est-ce que pour
changer votre image vous pourriez
arrêter d'avoir cette accent espagnol
si pour un film je travaille beaucoup
j'ai mes conseils du coup j'ai répète
comme un perroquet je peux d'ailleurs
je suis presque arrivé à pas avoir
d'accent
un film
ça fait longtemps que j'ai même entre
plus est-ce que pour changer votre image
pour y jouer une fille frigide qui
déteste l'amour
est-ce que pour changer votre image vous
pourriez dire non à un film d'Almodovar
je l'ai fait avant de travailler avec
lui mais pas maintenant parce que tu
sais lui avec ses sexes ça allait
prendre 17 ans hein allez reprendre si
jamais il me rappelle dans 7 ans
est-ce que pour changer votre image vous
pourriez vous la péter à mort et parler
de vous la 3e personne
elle est pas mal
je pourrais dire que le sexe ça vous
dégoûte
d'image lié aux histoires d'impôts on va
voir ce que vous seriez prêt à faire
pour changer votre image on va faire une
interview changement d'image
changer d'image vous êtes prêt à dire
que c'est important de payer ses impôts
et d'être solidaire des plus démunis
bien sûr
que je suis solidaire des plus démunis
et puis
chacun
au bord de quoi
est-ce que pour changer d'image vous
êtes prêt à offrir les droits de votre
prochain disque au reste du cœur Florent
fond du cœur c'est le truc qui marche le
mieux
quelque chose qui qui d'un seul coup
c'est formidable vraiment est-ce que
pour changer d'image dans le Luberon
plutôt qu'on Patagonie
forcément les endroits super dans le
Nord
bien sûr
on verra
on vérifiera mais je suis pas sûr
pour moi c'est tout pourri maintenant
il vient du nord
est-ce que vous soyez prêt à faire un
duo avec Juliette Juliette
qui jouait dans Juliette et Romeo
Juliette
[Musique]
une Victoire de la musique avec des
lunettes toutes bouclées est-ce que pour
changer d'image vous seriez prêt à
chanter moins fort
c'est pas vrai je prends plaisir à
chanter moins fort quand ça se présente
enfin quand la musique
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à chanter je
suis pour de Michel Sardou
c'était pour la peine de mort je pense
que comme un bonne humeur qui se
respecte à certains moments de ma vie tu
dois pouvoir te dire il y a des choses
qui se passent pour après tu résonne un
peu tu fais peut-être pas y aller mais
oui je pense qu'on peut avoir des excès
comme ça est-ce que pour changer l'image
vous soyez prêt à porter des strings en
cuir des strings en cuir mais je sais
même pas si j'en ai pas déjà porté
[Applaudissements]
il y a quand même des trucs rigolo de
temps en temps est-ce qu'il faut changer
d'image vous seriez prêt à porter des
t-shirts trop étroit pour devenir une
icône gay
ben écoute
moi j'ai rien contre les gays mais juste
qu'il soit pas contre moi trop contre
moi non non non non
c'est pareil c'est pareil j'ai aussi des
photos comme ça
ce qui était d'ailleurs un très bon plan
c'est que dès que je rencontrais des
homos qui commence à me faire mais tu
sais pas ce que tu rates
mon pote je sais très bien ce que je
rate pas
c'est surtout pas ça mais bon voilà un
moment c'est voilà c'est comme ça c'est
le destin pour plein de choses
est-ce que pour changer d'image Florent
vous êtes prêt à dire aux jeunes que la
drogue c'est mal et que vous n'avez
jamais pris je suis prêt à expliquer aux
mômes que les tarpé c'est comme l'alcool
attendez d'avoir tous vos neurones avant
dans les éliminer quelques-uns par
contre une fois que vous avez tous vos
neurones vous allez voir c'est vachement
sympa tu vois non mais c'est la vérité
c'est un moment c'est pas fait pour les
gamins mais quand tu es un peu plus
vieux tu mets un petit pet ça peut te
faire du bien surtout que tu viens faire
ce genre d'émission
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à défendre les
35 heures pour changer d'image pas du
tout
rien soit tu bosses mais bon trouver des
espèces de trucs intermédiaires ça fout
que le bordel
d'image vous seriez prêt à faire une
queue de cheval regarde
un porno pour changer d'image alors
quoi avec des moutons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu